الثمن هو عنوان لمسلسل الذي يعرض هذه
الايام على شاهد وام بي سي يقودنا اليوم
الحديث من نوع اخر ليس دراميا في طبيعه
الحال انما حياتي بحث ياخذنا الى النوع
خطر من الرجال الرجل السام في العلاقه
اوتوكس كمان هذا نوع من الرجال الذي يكون
مؤذيا في علاقته نسائيه والذي ينظر الى من
تعشقه بعين غير جاده وقلب يفقد الشعر لكن
المفاجئ في الامر ان هناك عدد لا باس به
من النساء ممن يقعون ضحيه لهذا النوع من
الرجال ويتجهن اليه بكامل
تقع النساء ضحيه الاقناع والتلاعب اللفظ
من هذا النوع من الرجال يتعطفنا معه
محاولات ان يكون اكثر قربا مع قناعه
بقدرتهن على التغيير عقول هؤلاء المزيد عن
الرجال السامين وصفاتهم مع الزميل او
الزميل يا ريت ساميه
تقول الحكمه في بلادك روسيا الانسان في
الحب ليس سيدا والحب اعمى لدرجه ان بعض
العاشقين يقعون في شباك مظلمه تترك اثرا
لا تمحه السنون الطوال فتياتم كثيرات
عندما يتعرفن الى الشباب يصعب عليهن
الوصول الى مشاعر الرجل وشخصيته الحقيقيه
المختبئه خلف اقنعه الحب والرومانسيه
والانا المتعجرفه بغرور مرحله قاسيه خلال
فتره التعارف تلاحظ فيها المراه ان الرجل
يحبها صباحا ويكره هذا ظهرا ويبرر ويعتذر
مساءا انه الرجل السام في العلاقه او
الرجل
الرجل الطوكسك اسمه يطلق على الرجل الخلطه
من سحر متعب لعقل الانثى وعدوانيه مفرطه
باسباب مختلفه وتنمر على اوصافها وسيطره
المطلقه على حركتها وسكنتها
[موسيقى]
العشق حاله الساحره من المشاعر الجميله
اغمض عينيك واتبعني حتى ان بعض المحبين
يرون في الشتاء ربيعا بين ان السؤال
المفصليه هنا كيف يمكن معرفه مشاعر الرجل
الحقيقيه ان كانت صدقه بالفعل او
استغلالتان تحت قناعن مو زياف
حسب راي الخبراء لا بد للمراه خلال فتره
التعارف من الانتباه لعده امور ابرزها
يكمن في ان يسود العقل على القلب في اتخاذ
القرارات عندما تشعر المراه بضعف في
تصرفاتها تبعا لحيائها ومشاعرها الرقيقه
ينصح الخبراء بعدم الانجرار وراء رغبه
الرجل والتخلي عن الطاعه العمياء ولابد من
معرفه ان الرجل السامه هو شخصيه مشوهه
فكريه ومريض عقليا ومزعزع الثقه بنفسه
ويحمل من الصراع بداخله ما يكفي لقتل كل
مشاعر المراه واحاسيسها وشخصيتها والتي
تعد ملكه جمال المخلوقات في الكون عبد
الجواد لصباح العربيه موسكو
حسيت حالي بحضر مسلسل روسي الحلو في انه
على الجواد هو الي عامله وعاش الدور يعني
فعلا سالنا الناس في العراق لماذا تتعاطف
المراه مع الرجل المعروف لانه الرجل
التاكسيك
[موسيقى]
الرجل مسموم عاده يكون انسان مريض الانسان
المريض يحتاج لعلاج بس المراه عاده عاده
تتعامل ويا هيك شخص اذا زوجها تحاول بكل
طريقه ترضي او تصلحه على موده تمشي امور
بيتها الرجال صعب لازم واحد يعني يكون سلس
واياه تتعاطف يعني ما تحكي عليه المراه
بتاكلوجياتها يعني تختلف عن الرجل تقدر
تحته الرجل اللي تقدر تحكي والاطفال
[موسيقى]
دائما حاول
نبي رغباته وبالمقابل ايضا نحاول انه نوصل
له الفكره الصحيحه عامله بالسياسه هي
السياسه اصلا هي اللي راح تخليه هيك فشنو
نسايسه طلباتك بالي يعجبه الاكلات اللي
يريدها مثلا على سبيل المثال
مع نفسك همم
للفوكس كمان هل هو اكثر جاذبيه هلا هون
شاطرين بالكلام المعسول يعني بيستعملوا
كلام حلو ليش الستات بتفضل تظل مع مع هن
نوع من الرجال لعده اسباب نادين اول شيء
ممكن انه تكون هي شايفه انه كاني عايشه
بعائله ابوها كانسان وبالتالي اما عاشت
بها الجو فش معنى انا ما رح اعرف اعيش
عرفته فبتقول انه اوكي او ممكن يكون سبب
ثاني انه بتعتبرها مثل ترنجكت شي حاجه
والصراحه يعني ما بعرف اذا بتوافقون
الرايه بس احنا ما فينا نصلح حدا اذا هو
مش شايف انه عنده مشكله اساس صح صح
والسبب الثالث ممكن انه همم بتصير مثل
يعني همم
في حال في حال في حاله فبتنجذب
للعامله سكسس في الستوري وانا اللي نجحت
انه انه همم سويت هذا الشيء وبدا يلفت
النظر على موضوع الستات وال- والامهات
بالمجمل يا اللي بتقبل بانه ضل مع شخصين
وبتنصح بنتها بعدين انه انت ما تقبلي
ومنشوفها كثير يعني بشوفها عندي بشوفها
بنشوفها بنسمعها كثير همم بنقول لاي ست
كتير مهم انه احنا بنربي اشياء يعني اجيال
لقدام
فاذا همم الاولاد
هذا الشيء قد ما انا اقول انت ما تقبلي
بكره بس تتجوزي انت بالنهايه هتقول طب ليش
انا مثل نفس الشيء
المهم انه كثير
التصرفات تكون صح لحتى
اكثر واكثر بها المشاكل رجل سم او رجل
توكسيك لعيد ماده هو مؤذن نفسيا وعقليا
للمراه وضحيته لجهه استنزاف طاقتها وقد
يقوده الموضوع الى القلق والاكتئاب اكيد
مثل ما انت قلتي لما عم يستنزف طاقتك
ويشكك بحالك اكيد انت همم ثقتك بنفسك تروح
مش عم بحكي عنك بس الست بالمجمع همم
سالتها بنفسها حتى هتنزل وهتكون تفوت
بالاكتئاب
والانزايتي والتوتر والستريس لانه همم كل
الوقت عايش بهاي الاجواء فهمم اكيد بنصحها
انه همم تاخذ قرار همم وما تطول كثير لا
تاخذ هذا القرار لانه رح يصير الشغل اكثر
واكثر همم
نتيجه مضمونه انه الواحد يفوت بالاكتئاب
والتوتر عندي عندك
هذا الموضوع كانت مع رجل اا نار نرجس
نرجستك فكانت الامور صعبه جدا عليها لحتى
انها تاخذ القرار توقف لانه هو بنظاره انه
هو عم بيهمها انه هي الغلط وهي صارت تشك
بحالها طيب يعني في رجل توكسك بس في امراه
كمان ممكن تكون توكسك شكرا كثير نادين
اللي قلت هذا الشيء لانه انا هذا اللي
دايما بقوله مش الرجال
هنكسك والنساء معصومين من هذا الشيء لا في
كثير همم رجال نساء واذا رجعنا على موضوع
الثمن اللي ذكرته هلا بالتقرير همم بس
الخياط انا بالنسبه لي كان نتيجه
فهو انا بشوفه منه رجل ههه
اعتقدت اللي ربتها امه عليها لحتى يطلع
انه لا يربته انه النساء كلها ما بتسوى او
كل النساء خائنات ما فينا نحنا نيجي نقول
كل الرجال
شخصيات علم نفس الايجابي ومدريبات حياتي